if you had to pick one driving
characteristic that separates a dominant
alpha team guy from everyone else
what in the teams what is it
well if guys in the teams you got to
know this but a lot of people out there
don't that like
pretty much everyone's an alpha male you
know you know
it's like nobody gives up the argument
ever
you know and usually it's you know
wrestling or fighting and
it always works itself out but
i think uh one thing i we were talking
about is gimmicks
like a lot of people in the teams i call
it a gimmick
everybody's good at everything pretty
much and does the job
but some people like just insane
skydivers
some guys are just phenomenal rock
climbers some guys are just
like swimming sons of guns you know
runners and wrestlers and fist fighters
and
there's you know some people just in the
guns i mean that's their passion some
people are
just phenomenal divers you know and i
was
i was always pretty good at everything
but not great
you know i couldn't outrun everybody i
could not fight everybody i couldn't out
swim everybody could not shoot everybody
and i just i i think mine was like
tactics
and just being as hard as i could and it
i i may have made it look easy but it
wasn't especially as i got older
it's no fun being a team guy when you're
44 you know
and you get up and you're like
all right yeah okay then i'm like i
better retire
i'm done with all this but yeah if that
if that
kind of makes sense yeah the other funny
thing about that is
um because in the teams no team guy ever
wants to give
any credit to a different team guy so if
someone was like
hey you know that that guy's a really
good shot and then someone immediately
but yeah
you ever he doesn't know how to swim
though yeah of course yeah we used to
talk about
always just like someone's always ready
no one's good at everything
did you work you know did you and if
they can't figure something out
they'll be like whatever [ __ ] that guy
no just walk away hey where are you
going yeah
yeah the uh you know one thing i'll say
that is pretty cool and i already
brought this up
like one of the things that that
separate like when i worked with that
first time and i saw you like being
humble
i was like man that's that to me
is the characteristic that you can tell
the guy is not just a good team guy but
an awesome team guy when he's
humble about what's going on and when i
was putting guys through training and i
know you saw this too the guys that
would come through training that thought
they were all badass and thought they
couldn't do anything wrong
they were always bad like they never did
a good job right right
and then the guys that were say hey man
i'm you know i'm looking forward to this
training i know we need
to need to get tuned up and and uh let
you know let me don't know what i can do
better those guys were there taking
notes they always kicked ass
they always did a good job yeah so that
being humble is uh well being humble too
is
i read a bunch of after-action reports
you know in my tours over there about
different situations different things
and
every time they were well written by
some guys but it was
you'll always carry this you will always
do this never do this
always do that and i kind of took that
an account when i wrote
like a serious after action report for
that deployment i wish you would have
saved it too this is pretty good yeah
first and foremost this is what worked
for us
in these months this environment this
temperature with this mission set
and what we had to do don't use this as
oh he said that so i'm going to do it
every time
no i mean use it as a guide everything
that teams is a toolbox
you pick it out when you need it and you
use it and you put it back away
and if it sits in there for 500 years
it's still worth having because the
timing pull it out you're gonna really
need it yep